[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
michelle tafoya nbc sunday night
football sideline reporter
past tense she worked her fifth super
bowl on sunday on nbc in peacock a
four-time winner for a sports emmy
outstanding personality sports reporter
former colleague at nbc and
not retiring but what was it like when
you walked off the field for the final
time
oh my gosh dan hi um
i'll tell you something i i had kept it
together and kept it together because
you know i've been planning on this for
years now
and then i decided as i was leaving you
know maybe i should just sort of look
back
at where i am walking away from and look
back at the field and just sort of take
it in and
remember this
and i lost it i lost it um
i didn't like saab but i i cried i i
looked back that stadium is beautiful so
high as you know
it was still full of energy and people
and
and i just looked at the lights and i
looked at the field and i said i'm not
going to be back like this here again or
at any stadium for that matter and
i kind of
i kind of like the whole thing sort of
flashed before my eyes it was it was it
was a moment um
sort of bittersweet uh but
amazing
how physically demanding
take us onto the field you're trying to
get aaron donald after the game and how
does that work where
game ends and then all of a sudden it's
chaos
they tell you and i'm when i say they
the team's pr staff your camera crew
your sideline producer everyone that's
helping says you stand here
we'll get aaron and you're standing
there and it's my nature to go chase the
guy down myself because that's like
where is he you know so i am we got to
get this done
so it's um you know it can be physically
it is chaotic but you don't care because
you're
you're you're single-mindedly pursuing
this this person and thinking about what
you're going to ask and so
you care less about the chaos you see
right through it somehow and you just
you just get it done but i will say i
was talking to him and when mcveigh came
up behind him to hug him my arm was
stuck between them that was a little bit
of an uncomfortable moment it was kind
of a weird sort of position to be in
and how much time do you know you have
with aaron donald post game on the field
i did i really didn't know dan um i
didn't know i i know someone in my ear
will will go wrap it you know if i'm
going too long
but
for me it says as long as it's
compelling and as long as it's uh you
know you don't want to keep the guy
forever he wants to go be with his
teammates you know you have a job to do
but you're trying to be sensitive to all
those elements of the moment
and um so i knew it was going to be
three questions maybe four max and i
think that's what we did but also you
know you have something because he's
crying
and then
you want to be sensitive to him being
sensitive himself
uh and there's that fine line of am i
milking this and
how do you judge that
um
you you just put it really nicely you
don't you don't want to milk it you
don't want to be like
let's just see how much we can get him
to cry
but you do want to
let him be authentic uh you want to know
what's behind the tears
you obviously on a human level we all
know what's there right it's this moment
of incredible victory of a lifetime of
waiting for justice you know that's all
that you don't want to put that into his
mouth you want to ask him you want him
to tell you what it is so you're trying
to find clever ways to get there um and
at the same time let him let him talk
about that final play because that that
did the game in that iced it right so
um
there's just a i don't know it's a
balancing act and you never get it
perfectly right but you try
and then rodney harrison pregame says
hey wouldn't be surprised if erin donald
walks away and i'm like wait rodney's
now an insider and i was going to text
him to say rodney do you what you just
said because now it's part of the game
and even afterwards
uh
you know are you thinking can i ask him
should i ask him how do i ask him about
retiring
yeah and i had to because if you don't
you're damned if you do damned if you
don't that minute dan because if people
if you don't ask and get criticized when
you do ask you get criticized but i had
to um and and in fact i used it in my
open too because rodney had reported
that to us that he was thinking about
you know look if i win this thing maybe
i'll go away and and call it a career so
we use that in my opening on camera and
then you gotta bookend it you have to
ask the question you just and and i
thought
it was kind of telling that he said i'm
just gonna soak this in for now and i
totally respected that and i knew we
probably weren't gonna get a definitive
answer but
you know when i did my first super bowl
it was pittsburgh jerome bettis was
thinking about retiring and i did i
recorded my post game interview with him
he told me he was going to retire and
then they they ditched my recorded
interview with him and grabbed someone
to do it live i think it was terrico who
stole that moment
oh you know
so i was just gonna i was gonna ask
more likely to walk away aaron donald or
sean mcvay
aaron donald i mean if i if i had to
weigh those
this you know we asked sean mcvay about
that on saturday we had a final
conference call with him and he's like
shoot they asked me you know am i going
to do this until i'm 60 well so
but but then i've also seen some
interesting little
or i should say picked up on some
interesting vibes coming out of industry
folks that think you know he has an
opportunity to go do what john gruden
once did which is walk away from
coaching for a while do some tv
relax and he he's young enough he could
go back to coaching again my gosh he's a
super bowl champion i was told that this
morning
by a source who said there's interest on
both sides with espn and sean mcvay and
my source said i don't know if it's a
leverage play
same thing with aaron donald i don't
know if this is a leveraged play same
thing with kyler murray with what's
going on with him leverage play
it well with kyler it would seem more of
a leverage play he's so early in his
career and we were talking about aaron
donald how great he is
but think about you know guys that did
walk away when they were at their prime
and they were still able to enjoy the
rest of their lives i mean aaron donald
has worked his
uni am i allowed to say ass off on your
show yes you just did okay okay he's
worked his ass off for so long i thought
one of the things he said in the
interview was so sweet he said i
promised my five-year-old daughter that
i would win a super bowl and now he's
delivered that to her
maybe he's promising her more more
daddy-daughter time too we don't know
that and so you know for a guy who just
his whole life is about work and staying
fit
maybe he's ready who knows yeah but
maybe he buys her a couple of ponies
michelle and he continues to play i mean
if i if you say to your five-year-old do
you want a couple of ponies or do you
want daddy to be home all the
time i know what my five-year-old would
have said ponies
no oh of course not of course
i'll take cash mom i don't don't buy the
pony give me money
give me the american express card and
i'm good no you know i do remember my
daughter once uh i came home from the
end of the season and there was a note
on my desk that said i'm so glad
football season is over
and you know it it just yanked it it was
like oh my gosh you don't think your
kids are thinking about that but they
are they they love you being around um
everyone has their own story so i'll be
really eager to see what aaron does he's
a phenomenal player he look he's
achieved about everything you can
achieve right what do you have left to
do except i guess make more money
michelle tafoya nbc sunday night
football sideline reporter uh odell
beckham and that storyline post game for
you
uh the importance of of hearing from obj
was was what
well i i we didn't get to hear from him
i didn't get to see it either dan what
did he say post game was there was there
somewhere that he spoke because what i
saw was he came back out onto the
sideline dressed in you know his sweats
i saw him celebrating he didn't he
looked happy but for a guy who caught a
touchdown in the in the super bowl and
then
you know you saw it happen
it's one of those no one hit him it was
non-contact it was this this moment if
the guy has torn his acl again
i i'm crushed for him
we had a really great discussion with
obj that the week of the super bowl
where he confessed a lot of stuff
about how the catch in new york was a
blessing and a curse be careful what you
wish for because it changed his life
both good and bad
um how he was too young maybe for that
all that attention in new york city um
what happened in cleveland how he felt
when he left cleveland how much soul
searching he did
and how he's really he feels he's grown
up a lot from all of those things it was
a truly compelling interview with him
that we had
and so we were all a little heartbroken
for him not to be able to finish that
game i was also wondering about him in
the media you know it's another knee
injury
uh
good looking guy charisma
yeah could you see him in a in a studio
environment
that's a great point i could because i i
don't think people understand
how how
deep this kid is as the thinker and um
because you don't get that opportunity
very often to just sit down with a guy
with no cameras around and just talk and
that's what we did with him during the
week when we went up to rams practice
and
it was
we were all just like
spellbound i mean we're all just i don't
want to exaggerate but we were all i
don't know that people were taking notes
because we were just listening and
absorbing what this guy's been through
and it was fascinating now
i think he can find a way to channel
that he is a good looking guy he's got a
lot of accomplishments
on his resume he knows the game
um people
he he can you can think of him as a
polarizing character i think he's going
to come around to being a beloved
character well we've seen wide receivers
do this who knew randy moss would be a
good studio analyst or michael irvin
would be a charismatic guy like that
this this happens and it feels like he
would be a natural so let the audience
know what is next for michelle tafoya
well you know what's gotten picked up
the most is that i'm i'm helping to run
a campaign in minnesota we've got a guy
running for governor there kendall falls
who
i'm
very supportive of and am going to be
the co-chair of his campaign um
dan i know this is going to sound corny
and dumb i don't care i really don't
care what people think
every morning i wake up and there is a
palpable
pull at my chest like a oh you've got to
go do something that helps people out we
are in a bad place
in this country
i am the daughter of american dreamers
you know my dad's a first generation um
latino here my mom grew up poor dirt
poor in the depression
my whole family lived the american dream
i believe in it
and uh
i gotta
i gotta help in whatever way i can i've
taken enough of the american dream i
want other people to believe in it
um i want people to be stop being told
what they can't do
and being told what they can do
uh because the opportunities here are
limitless and i'm tired of people being
told uh you can't get that no it's
unfair here there is a lot of unfairness
in life
but there's a lot more
opportunity and i i i just need to find
a way to help
move that along somehow someway
uh it's an honor to have worked with you
and uh right back at you pally and uh
and good luck and and hopefully you get
that that uh quality time at home
because
you know i left espn and people said
you're crazy and i said i'm i'm not
crazy if i'm going home to my kids
but exactly you know what mix in a
viking game occasionally maybe do like a
pre-season sideline you know just to
keep ready just in case like tom brady i
mean who knows michelle
who knows more likely to come back you
or tom brady
tom brady okay
no question uh
thank you michelle
thank you dan appreciate it be well
michelle tafoya nbc uh football night
america's sideline reporter